they're light and refreshing but robot
no hey guys it's Alex so after I made my
single cooking video I've had so many
questions from you guys who are paired
up on how to cook for two good news is
I've got you covered
today I'm going to show you three
recipes to make an incredible
three-course romantic dinner I even bet
you could make this whole three-course
dinner in under 15 minutes so whether
you're trying to spice up a weeknight
with your significant other or impress
someone new these recipes are for you I
didn't mean to run so starting with the
appetizer we're gonna be making these
really pretty tomato mozzarella skewers
they're light and refreshing and they're
a little bit fancy these are super
simple I'm gonna start with a mini
skewer or a toothpick just skewer your
cherry tomato right on there next I'm
gonna pop on a piece of fresh mint so
usually you see these with basil basil
works great here too but I really like
the flavor of the mint it's very
refreshing and lastly just pop on a
little piece of fresh mozzarella and
there you have it you definitely want to
go for fresh mozzarella the kind that's
in the water you could also find the
mozzarella that's already in the small
balls and just pop that on told you it
was easy so I'm just gonna drizzle on
some extra virgin olive oil I'm also
gonna drizzle on a little bit of
balsamic reduction you could also just
use balsamic vinegar I'm just doing this
with a spoon there's really no rhyme or
reason next I'm just gonna top with a
little flaky salt and some fresh pepper
all right appetizer is done they look so
good I like when my food looks homemade
moving right along to the main course
for our main dish we're gonna be making
seared scallops and creamy orzo I love
scallops because they're super buttery
and rich they're easy to make and
they're super romantic I don't like them
Fabio of the sea to kick it off we're
gonna season our scallops first I am
just gonna Pat them dry this will help
us get a really nice sear with that
crusty edge on the scallop this is a
good like affordable fancy seafood
option especially if you're unsure about
your date you don't want to splurge on
the lobster until at least the fifth day
right I wouldn't know what so now I'm
just gonna season our scallops with a
little salt some fresh cracked pepper
give them a flip and season the other
side all right these are looking good
over to the stove we go
so before we sear our scallops I'm gonna
get our orzo going since I'll take a
minute to cook on a pot over high heat
I'm gonna add in my orzo orzo is great
because it's again a little bit fancy
and different but it's like a cross
between pasta and rice some chicken
stock and some dry white wine now I'm
gonna cover the pot and bring it to a
boil once it's boiling I'm gonna take
the lid off reduce it to low and let it
cook until all the liquid is absorbed so
why my orzo reduces and simmers I'm
gonna be searing the scallops I have a
nonstick pan over medium-high heat and
I'm adding about a tablespoon of oil we
want to make sure your oil is nice and
hot before you add in the scallops so
that they get a nice sear gonna pop them
right in there just a couple minutes on
each side and then once they have a nice
golden brown crust on the bottom that's
the time to flip it so now that my
scouts are seared I'm adding two
tablespoons of butter right into the pan
and a clove of grated garlic now I'm
just basing the scallops in that garlic
butter so add awesome flavor and help us
cook them through a little bit more
lastly I'm adding a splash of wine it's
date night oh it could use a little wine
now that they're cooked through I want
to take them directly off of the heat so
that they don't overcook
they look and smells so good now my orzo
has absorbed all that liquid
now I'm gonna flavor it up with some
force on cheese this is a really
delicious almost like a cream cheese
with some herbs in there you can always
add a different kind of cheese and fresh
herbs and about a cup of some chopped
spinach for veggies of course give that
a stir
all right our orzo looks nice and creamy
time to plate the main dish all right so
we've got all of our components time to
bring this dish together so I'm gonna
start by just spending our orzo down oh
it looks so good so creamy what I love
so much about this dish is it's really
something you could see yourself getting
at a restaurant but it's so fast and
easy to put together it's like my own
date with Fabio so now I'm just gonna
pop our scallops right onto the orzo if
you're cooking this dish with your date
you could totally split the workload up
someone works on the orzo someone works
on the scallops teamwork makes the dream
work so now I'm gonna finish the dish
off with a nice drizzle of extra virgin
olive oil some more fresh cracked pepper
some flaky salt little over your
shoulder for good luck always need good
luck on a date and some fresh chopped
chives beautiful voila we've got our
main dish it was fast and easy to make
pretty impressive and always delicious
I'm getting real hungry but first we
gotta make dessert for dessert we're
going to be making chocolate lava cakes
now this is a super decadent rich
dessert but I have a little trick we're
gonna be cooking these in mugs in the
microwave all right these are super
simple we're gonna start with a half a
cup of flour 1/4 a cup of cocoa powder
1/4 a cup of white granulated sugar 1/4
a teaspoon of salt and 2 teaspoons of
baking powder so I know we're making a
date night dessert right now but these
lava cakes are also super awesome if you
have kids give that a nice mix and to
our dry ingredients
I'm adding 1/4 a cup of oil and 1/4 a
cup of milk
that'll give that another mix all right
so we have a nice smooth batter now I'm
just gonna split it between two mugs and
finally I'm gonna
pop two chocolate truffles right in the
center push them right on down with your
finger and now we're gonna microwave
these for 70 seconds each alright our
cakes look delicious they cooked up
quite nicely in the microwave
I'd recommend serving them with a little
ice cream but that's just me
either way I'm sure you're gonna love
them to kick it off we have our
beautiful tomato mozzarella and mint
skewers hmm super simple super easy
super delicious alright moving on to our
main dish our seared scallops with
creamy orzo seriously this is some
restaurant quality stuff the scouts are
buttery and salty and flavorful and it's
perfectly balanced with that creamy orzo
and last but certainly not least our
chocolate lava cakes oh I'm really
excited to eat this it's magic forget
date dessert this is like every night
thing well there you go three romantic
recipes perfect for a date take yourself
on a date wine and dine yourself you
deserve it if you do make them be sure
to tag me on Instagram I'd love to see
your work and I'll see you guys next
time oh yes
[Music]
you